Rochelle wrote in Rochelle said hey how
do you guys deal with people who smell
bad in a polite way does it depend
whether it is a co-worker or in a
personal situation this is tough
bad smelling people can sort of beyond
the borders of etiquette questions and
it can be very very difficult um let's
say it's someone that has let's assume
for this conversation it's not someone
that you would just straight-up say you
stink right like if you bumped into a
sibling and their breath is terrible you
may just go breath stinks yeah gotta
brush your teeth you have to you have to
do something but the trend let's assume
it's people where you need to have some
kind of uh disk discretion and etiquette
okay bad breath is one where you could
approach it a couple ways you could
position yourself during the
conversation such that you're not in in
the you know in in the firing range so
to speak you could pull out a piece of
gum for yourself and offer one to the
person who has the bad breath although
very often gum just sort of combines
with the bad breath smell doesn't
necessarily replace it which can be a
little bit odd uh so bad breath is one
that you can you can sort of deal with
diplomatically if you're in a situation
where there's someone working in it at
the desk next to you and they just have
body odor like really bad body odor
that's tougher I mean I I don't if
you're the same level as them at work
maybe you go to a supervisor and ask to
have the conversation off the record and
see what the supervisor might suggest
but that gets very very tough it there
would be no reason for me to bring that
up to them I don't think I mean I that
would be just too comfortable
uncomfortable for me to even want to
bring up I don't I think I just let it
go but what it would let let's assume
it's really bad I mean I've experienced
bad Bo before were you you really can't
be around I mean it's gag were really
you can't work around that every day
yeah I get that um I think I would just
have to go through with it
I mean subtle comments maybe I think the
gum uh offering someone gum would work
for something that just works you know
they're having bad breath for one day
that that maybe like a little subtle
trick to to get them to smell a little
better would it fall under the heading
of subtle to say if their birthday is in
and it's my it's February to show up
with a loofah and body wash it's a
here's a little early birthday gift for
you or is that not subtle enough in your
mind yeah I think that would be a little
obvious and I think most people who have
an issue with body odor
are kind of aware of it too do you think
so I don't know yeah I've look back when
we worked well actually let me not say
anything about where because people
might identify this but there was a time
where I would regularly be in a place
where for sort of cultural reasons I
think showering was less common and also
using any kind of product when you
shower was less common it wasn't a
financial thing was an ideological thing
completely and people would stink and in
speaking with friends about the issue
they seemed convinced that the people
don't realize it because they're around
it all the time when they've stopped
using soap and deodorant they've gotten
used to their own smell and that they
don't realize that they stink yeah I get
that too but you know those people have
close friends and family that are gonna
mention it and unless they're in the
same boat with them yeah they may not
read in deep they may never know you
know yeah yeah yeah uh I I was uh once
at a place where it was a sort of uh it
was a red let's color restaurant this to
pick up for lack of a better term and I
was sat at a table that was next to
where there had been three baby
strollers left and all of a sudden I
started getting the smell of dirty
diaper and I start looking around and I
don't see any babies next to me and I
see that there are babies on the other
side but then I noticed that there are
these strollers right next to me and
very clearly the UH it was it was three
moms with three babies one of them had
decided rather than throw out the dirty
diaper keep it somewhere on that
stroller but keep the stroller near my
table rather than their table
fortunately the next table over was sat
and they smelled it immediately and said
to the waitress that was working listen
I don't want to be that person but we're
about to order food here and those
strollers smell like like baby diapers
dirty baby diapers is there anything
that we can do about this the waitress
said yeah you know those really should
be there's actually kinda blocking the
doorway and
way and she went over and told the three
moms and three moms to be honest didn't
look very put off by it they just move
they said we're leaving anyway and they
left and smell went away do you think
you would have confronted the waitress
about it if those other people didn't
get to you to them beforehand you know I
think I would have yeah I do think I
would have because I would not have
really been able to eat in that
situation you know but if there's a
person that you're eating next to and
they have bad body odor yeah that that's
the kind of thing you just have to put
up with ya know sometimes you just have
to put up with it and say hey you know
what this is a temporary thing it will
pass but yeah I I've not ever been the
best at dealing with those types of
situations Rochelle if you have tips
please let us know